Transcription: Héloïse Gauvrit
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir à tous !
Dans la salle ce soir,
je sais qu’il y a une personne
qui s’appelle Dominique.
Il y a un Antoine, il y a un Luigi,
un Raphaël, un Tristan,
un Maxime et même une Camélia.
Moi, c’est Joseph,
je ne suis pas mentaliste.
J’ai simplement demandé
à regarder la liste des invités.
(Rires)
Mais pourquoi ?
C’est parce que, parmi toutes
les personnes que j’ai citées,
y compris moi,
on a deux points communs.
Le premier, c’est qu’on a
tous galéré à venir à ce TEDx
parce que c’était hyper loin de Paris.
Le deuxième,
c’est un point commun qu’on partage tous
et tout être humain sur Terre.
C’est qu’on a tous connu
au moins une épreuve.
Mais avant de parler d'un mot,
il faut savoir le définir.
Alors une épreuve, c’est un événement
de la vie qui amène de la complexité,
de la tension,
et parfois beaucoup de tristesse.
Mais une épreuve, c’est également un défi.
Un défi qui, si on décide de le relever,
nous permet de prendre conscience
de l’importance d’un bon moment.
Et ce soir, avant de vous raconter mon
épreuve, tout commence par une lettre.
« Cher Papa,
je suis en train de lire
une lettre qui s’adresse à toi,
sauf que je n’avais pas prévu de la lire
devant 300 personnes, à mon premier TEDx.
Je t’avoue que j’ai un peu le trac.
Même beaucoup le trac.
D’autant plus que ce bout
de papier ne me sert à rien.
Car ce soir, tout est écrit là.
Alors j’ai quelques questions à te poser.
Pourquoi tu te réveilles tous les jours
à 14h au lieu de profiter de moi ?
Pourquoi tu flirtes
avec trois femmes en même temps,
alors que tu as tout l’amour de ton fils ?
Et pourquoi tu m’engueules quand
je ramène un 9 sur 20 des cours,
alors que j’ai galéré à tricher
pour obtenir cette note ?
Alors, quand je parle de toi comme ça,
oui, on dirait que
je parle de mon meilleur ami.
Mais non, je parle bien de toi !
De cet homme qui me donne
le plus de motivation sur cette Terre.
De cet homme, qui avec un simple regard,
me dit que tout est possible
et de ne jamais abandonner.
De cet homme
à qui je peux confier
chacun de mes problèmes.
Et pour toutes ces raisons,
tu étais indispensable à ma vie.
Le fait que tu ne sois plus là Papa,
c’était, c’est et ce sera
toujours ma plus grande épreuve. »
Et pour vous la raconter ce soir,
on va revenir quelques années en arrière.
Vous voyez ce petit bonhomme
derrière, là ? C’était moi.
À cette époque, il y avait trois choses
pour me rendre vraiment heureux.
Les pizzas, les grasses matinées
et mon fameux doudou.
Je l’ai encore, d’ailleurs.
Je voulais rester enfant
toute ma vie, mais j’ai dû grandir.
Alors 18 ans, l’adolescence,
la première moustache, j’en étais fier.
Ah, je me pensais invincible.
Je n’avais peur de rien,
sauf de deux choses :
de rater ce fichu bac
et que mes parents soient déçus de moi,
et du regard des autres.
J’étais comme la plupart des ados,
en demande d’approbation.
Je publiais des photos sur Instagram
et je supprimais celles
qui avaient le moins de like.
Je pensais qu’en obtenant ce bac,
je serais libre et adulte.
Mais alors « adulte » pour moi,
je ne vais pas vous mentir,
c’était les filles, les soirées,
les voyages, l’argent
et encore les filles.
Mais, est-ce que c’est vraiment ça,
être adulte ?
Je ne pense pas,
en tout cas, la vie m’a montré que non.
Parce que, le 21 mai 2014,
je me réveille et c’est une journée
totalement normale pour moi.
Je vais à la bibliothèque
de mon quartier pour réviser le bac
et je reçois un appel de ma tante.
Je décroche.
Elle m'annonce que mon papa vient
de faire une crise cardiaque.
Alors, je me souviens même,
j’ai cette énorme boule au ventre
qui est apparue d’un seul coup.
J’avais du mal à respirer,
j’étais comme paralysé.
Malgré ça,
je cours dans les rues de Paris.
Je vais à l’hôpital, je rentre
dans la chambre et je vois mon papa.
Allongé sur un lit.
Les yeux fermés.
C'est trop tard.
Et à ce moment précis, je me rappelle
très bien avoir fait quelque chose.
J’ai fermé les yeux dans l’espoir
que tout ça ne soit qu’un cauchemar.
Et à ce moment-là,
j’avais l’impression que tout s’écroulait,
comme une structure de dominos
et ça ressemble un peu à ça.
Je sais ce que vous vous dites.
Oui, il y a beaucoup
de dominos sur la photo,
parce que, oui, j’ai pu constater,
que l’arrivée d’une épreuve
peut parfois en déclencher bien d’autres.
Le premier domino, c’était mon père.
Le deuxième, ma grand-mère
qui part quelques mois plus tard.
Le troisième, la femme la plus forte
que j’aie jamais connue,
qui tombe en burn out,
ma mère.
Et devant vous, ce soir, vous avez
le dernier domino qui est tombé.
Parce que, oui, toutes ces épreuves
accumulées m’ont fait tomber
et j’ai pu remarquer que
lorsque l’on vit plusieurs épreuves,
il y a des conséquences
physiques et mentales sur l’humain.
Des conséquences que je voulais
vraiment vous lister sous cette image.
Premièrement, il y a l’énergie.
Moi, j’étais tout
sauf une canette de Red Bull.
J’avais pris l’habitude
de soulever des poids lourds à la salle,
et là, je ne soulevais plus rien.
Mon physique, il était plus
devenu couché que développé.
Ensuite, il y a la libido.
Ah, la libido...
Les stars, quand ça ne va pas,
elles se réfugient dans deux choses :
le sexe et la drogue.
La drogue, ce n’était pas trop mon truc.
Le sexe, j’étais puceau...
Et je ne connais aucun ado qui a débuté
sa vie sexuelle aussi mollement que moi.
J’avais beau chercher : la seule chose qui
était dure chez moi, c’était ma vie.
(Rires)
Ensuite, il y a le sommeil.
Je vous l’ai dit,
j’étais fan de grasses matinées.
Et je me suis vite rendu compte
qu’une nuit pouvait être très longue
lorsqu’on garde les yeux ouverts.
Et le moral ? Ah... mon moral,
il diminuait jour après jour.
Jusqu’à la fois où j’ai ressenti l’envie
de faire un saut en parachute
du cinquième étage, sans parachute.
Ensuite, l'argent.
Ah, si j’avais su
qu’un enterrement coûtait aussi cher,
j’aurais pris plus soin de mon papa.
Et il y a le manque -
Je ne vous parle pas du manque d’argent,
mais du manque de l’être aimé.
Et enfin, la vie.
Est-ce que j’ai vraiment
besoin de développer
après tout ce que je vous ai raconté ?
Alors oui !
J’allais mal
et je n’étais pas au top de ma forme,
mais moi et mon fameux doudou,
on s’est promis de tout faire
pour aller mieux. Alors c’est parti !
Psychiatres, psychologues,
acupuncteurs, guérisseurs, hypnotiseurs
et même un marabout que j’ai trouvé
en banlieue parisienne.
Il a voulu m’escroquer de 400 euros.
Mais on ne me la fait pas à moi,
j’ai fait une école de commerce !
(Rires)
Malheureusement, rien n’a fonctionné.
Même pas le virement
que j’ai fait au marabout, d’ailleurs.
À croire qu’il avait fait de meilleures
écoles de commerce que moi.
Et pendant des mois,
voire des années, je me suis isolé.
Je me suis écarté de beaucoup de monde.
Je restais seul et je pensais que je
devais être seul avec cette douleur.
J’étais là, chaque matin,
à me regarder dans le miroir
et à prendre cette fameuse pilule
qu’on appelle antidépresseurs.
Et puis un beau jour,
ma maman vient me voir.
Elle me parle d’une dernière
solution que je n’ai pas encore essayée :
un groupe de parole pour le deuil
et pour les jeunes.
Je me dis : « C’est quoi, ce truc ? »
Mais bon, j’en avais marre de regarder
les murs blancs de ma chambre,
alors je me dis : « Pourquoi pas ? »
J’y vais un lundi soir,
c’est à deux pas de chez moi.
Je  rentre dans la pièce
et je vois six jeunes sur des chaises.
Avec moi, ça fait sept.
Donc, sept épreuves.
Et vous savez ce que je vois ?
Des milliers de dominos.
Alors, je m’assois et j’écoute.
Et je vois ce jeune homme qui parle de la
mort de sa mère, mais avec courage !
Je vois cette jeune fille,
qui parle de comment elle a perdu
son petit copain en accident de moto,
mais elle en parle
avec dignité et elle m’inspire.
Et à mon tour, quand c’est à moi
de raconter mon histoire,
je n’ai que des regards
bienveillants braqués sur moi.
Et là, pour la première fois
depuis quatre longues années,
je ne me sens plus seul.
A travers la parole, on était en train
de créer du lien et de l’entraide.
Et à ce moment-là,
j’ai compris que la parole, c’était bien
plus fort qu’un million de médicaments.
Je suis très heureux d’être devant vous,
parce que ça va mieux.
Le moral est revenu.
Et oui, je suis en grande forme.
Et ça, oui, c’est grâce à
ce fameux groupe de paroles.
Mais c’est également grâce à
trois actions que j’ai mises en place,
et qui font l’homme
que je suis devenu aujourd’hui.
Je voulais vraiment vous les partager.
La première action,
c’est que j’ai créé ma chaîne YouTube
pour mettre des vidéos en ligne.
Pourquoi ? Pour aider n’importe
quel jeune qui pourrait vivre une épreuve.
Je ne pensais pas
qu’une simple chaîne YouTube
pourrait faire vivre une telle émotion.
Parce que, oui, à l’époque, ça fait
quelques mois que je publie des vidéos.
Et un jour, je décide d’en mettre
une un peu plus profonde, différente.
C’est une vidéo qui parle de la mort
de mon père et ce que j’ai ressenti.
Alors il est 20h, je suis chez moi.
J’hésite à appuyer sur le bouton
« publier » et je me lance.
La vidéo est en ligne. Au fond de moi,
j’espère que pas trop de gens la verront.
Je vais me coucher et le lendemain matin,
je vais à l’école de commerce.
Sauf que j’ai oublié une seule chose...
C’est que la moitié de ma classe
est abonnée à ma chaîne YouTube !
Je vais en cours.
Et à la pause, il y a une jeune fille
du nom de Manon qui vient me voir.
Je ne connaissais rien de Manon.
C’était juste une camarade de classe,
on se disait bonjour.
Elle vient me voir et elle me dit :
« Joseph, j’ai vu la vidéo que
tu as publiée hier sur la chaîne YouTube,
et ça m’a fait bizarre.
Parce que moi aussi, mon père
est mort quand j’avais cinq ans.
Et pour ce que tu as dit, merci ! »
Ce « merci » peut paraître
anodin pour beaucoup de monde.
Moi, il m'a montré une chose.
C’est qu’on peut faire
de notre vulnérabilité une force,
et chacun d’entre nous peut le faire.
Ce « merci », il m’a également
motivé à passer à ma deuxième action,
qui est de passer
une certification de coach.
Quand je dis coach,
ce n’est pas coach sportif.
Vous l’aurez compris, ce n’est pas trop
mon domaine, mais coach de vie,
pour accompagner les personnes
dans l’atteinte de leurs objectifs.
Et ces deux premières actions,
elles résument très bien la dernière,
qui est que je me suis promis d’aider.
Mais alors aider qui ? Aider les personnes
à comprendre que vivre une épreuve,
ce n’est pas un problème, c’est de ne pas
en parler qui est un problème.
Parce que, oui, lorsqu’on vit une épreuve,
le plus dur,
ce n’est pas l’événement en lui-même,
mais c’est de croire
qu’on est seul dans notre combat
et qu’on ne peut en parler à personne.
Je sais ce que vous vous dites
au fond de vous : « Oui mais Joseph...
C’est dur d’en parler !
C’est dur de se confier ! »
Oui...
je sais.
Parler d’un deuil, d’un accident,
d’un mal-être que vous avez
au fond de vous, oui, c’est dur.
Oui, on peut être jugé.
Oui, certaines personnes
pourront ne pas vous comprendre.
Mais vous connaissez la bonne nouvelle ?
C’est que vous ne voulez pas
vous rapprocher de ce genre de personne.
Pour terminer,
j’aimerais vous parler d’un métier,
c’est un métier qui cartonne en Amérique.
C’est le « Happiness Manager ».
Alors, c’est quelqu’un
qui arrive en entreprise
et qui est en charge
du bonheur des salariés.
Du bonheur des salariés ?
Mais en fait, on est tous
le « happy manager » de nos proches,
peu importe l’épreuve qu’on a connue.
Son importance, sa durée,
on a tous la possibilité,
le pouvoir d’en faire
un cadeau, une joie pour autrui.
Je sais que vous pensez à
une épreuve bien précise au fond de vous.
Et vous avez ce pouvoir.
Et comme dirait mon pote, Spiderman :
« Tout pouvoir implique
de grandes responsabilités. »
Et c’est notre responsabilité
d’avoir le courage d’être nous-même,
pour permettre aux autres de le faire.
Le seul risque qu’on prend
c’est de se sentir mieux,
de faire des rencontres
et de créer des liens de malade
et d’inspirer les autres.
Aujourd’hui, à l’heure où je vous parle,
je suis très heureux d’avoir
des personnes de mon entourage
qui utilisent ce pouvoir au quotidien.
Et ce soir, ils voulaient
vous faire passer un message.
Jeune fille : J’ai vécu beaucoup
de rejets étant jeune.
Jeune homme : Mon ex-copine
m’a trompé avec mon colocataire,
qui était également
l’un de mes meilleurs amis.
JF 2 : J’ai vécu la dépression
et souffert d’anorexie pendant deux ans.
JF 3 : J’ai perdu 20 kilos
suite à un épisode dépressif.
JH 2 : J’ai vécu la pauvreté et la misère
une partie de mon enfance.
JF 4 : J’ai subi une douloureuse
rupture après huit ans de relation.
JH 3 : Enfant,
j’ai frôlé la mort deux fois.
JF 5 : J’ai souffert d’anxiété sociale
pendant toute mon enfance.
JH 4 : J’ai perdu ma grand-mère
le jour de mes huit ans.
Ce soir, je vous ai partagé
un bout de mon histoire
qui est désormais la vôtre d’ailleurs.
Et pour ce moment, pour ce cadeau,
du fond du cœur : Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)